fallout continues to reverberate in the
city of Atlanta over the district
attorney's decision to charge two
officers involved in the death of
Rashard Brooks the police union they're
confirming officers walked off the job
called out sick in higher numbers than
usual after the charges were announced
earlier Garret Rolf the former Atlanta
police officer who shot and killed
Brooks turned himself in he's facing 11
charges including felony murder which
could carry the death penalty and Devon
Brosnan the second officer involved is
out on bail after turning himself in
he's facing three charges including
aggravated assault earlier he and his
lawyer spoke with the media disputing a
key thing the district attorney said
about being a state's witness right now
the DA is charged him with a crime so
he's a defendant there and he's not
gonna answer you know the DA's questions
you know while they bring these false
charges against him so you know I regret
that the district attorney apparently
was given a misinformation yesterday and
and Oscar Brosnan is not going to be a
quote state's witness and president
Trump is defending police when asked to
comment on the case last night I thought
it was a terrible situation but you
can't resist a police officer and you
know if you have a disagreement you have
to take it up after the fact it was a
very sad very very sad thing it's going
to be up to justice I hope he gets a
fair shake because police have not been
treated fairly in our country they have
not been treated fairly Emily let's go
to you first I I am curious about how
the state's district attorney got that's
so wrong I mean saying that the officer
with rosna was going to be a state's
witness and then having his lawyer walk
that back and say no that's not true it
that seems like quite an extraordinary
thing exactly we watched as the lawyer
came on TV and said he's not a state's
witness he's just a witness and he's
also his own defendant I agree with you
I thought that was extraordinary and it
certainly doesn't bode well at least for
public opinion of that prosecutor I'd
like to speak for a moment on this blue
flu what did we think was going to
happen I spoke with the Seattle
police officer who told me that after he
was attacked by explosives metal bricks
beer bottles but he had to wash his
uniform three times to get the feces and
urine out of it he said he can handle
threats and insults but this level of
vitriol and violence is a whole
different story last Friday the 12th
turned into 12 day which turned into
kill a cop day and the FBI was working
with individual departments across the
country on threat assessments and
strategy while we watched on video as
cops were hit in the head with
skateboards because wearing a riot
helmet is considered militarization or a
sign of aggression
protesters are now carrying things
designed specifically to withstand or
probably test police write tactics like
plywood for rubber bullets and cops are
getting ACAB scrawled on receipts and
now prosecutors are seeking the death
penalty every officer I know is depleted
and exhausted and deeply saddened right
now and still committed to the
communities that they serve that they
are a part of but in terms of a positive
future this has set us back 10 steps and
as always the people with the most to
lose are those ones who are quiet 1 what
about down there in Atlanta the the
family was there last night of course I
was very moving comments that she made
especially when we saw the video about
Rashard Brooks being kicked as he as he
died there after being shot I was very
sad to me I think lots of people saw it
as inhumane no matter what confrontation
had taken place the man was ailing if
not dead and there was a long period
before they even sought medical
attention for him so I think you know
that's that's just sad and I wish it
hadn't happened but it certainly was
something that pulled at your heart in
terms of what's going on down in Atlanta
with the police I just think it's
important that we not overstate the case
because what I read from the police
department and the mayor was that the
police have more than enough staff to
not only protect the city but to give
adequate response to any incidents that
might occur but the big point to me Dana
said police take an oath unlike me or
you they take an oath to do their job so
when they don't show up they're breaking
that oath they're breaking their word to
us that they are operating under state
authority is armed people representing
us all and when they don't show up they
are not keeping that faith they're
breaking with that trust to my mind and
you think that yourself well gosh
they're human beings they're upset but
you know think about it why the man who
the officer that killed a man is going
through a total full legal process he
will have his day in court he had the
opportunity and will have the
opportunity to give all the testimony
and evidence and we'll all be considered
this was the actions of a DA and a grand
jury and that's you know that's what
every American deserves and he can be
assured his rights will be fully
protected he is not going to be short on
legal protections in this manner so I
mean you gotta ask yourself Jesse does
he think does he think he's above the
law I hope not well he did turn himself
in today Jesse on time and he has a
lawyer and of course he will get a
chance to defend himself though there's
a lot of complications here and to
Emily's point about police morale that
is also happening all across the country
yeah I mean it's a tough situation but I
mean the police officers not above the
law and he's not below it because look
what happened so much fake news and
smears coming from this DA the cop never
flipped that was a lie and he says that
this guy other officer kicked the
suspect when he was on the ground so he
gets up and he shows a screen grab from
surveillance video with the officers leg
cops back in the kicking motion why
didn't he just show the whole video I
wonder why I didn't show the whole video
because I'm pretty sure he didn't kick
the dead man I'm pretty sure he was
either stepping over him or running
towards him to give him a DES and he
didn't just stand there whistling in the
wind in less than a minute he was back
to the body administering CPR
trying to save the guy's life the other
thing you keep hearing he's shot in the
back he's shot in the back yeah
technically he was shot in the back
because usually when suspects punch
officers in the face and flee and shoot
them with Tasers
you're not running backwards you're
running forwards and you're turning and
shooting that's why the bullets were
discharged from the officers firearm in
the back the other thing as the DI comes
out and says this guy was jovial when
when our jovial people punching officers
in the face and shooting tasers at their
head I don't think he knows what jovial
means and under Georgia law a Taser is a
lethal weapon and you're allowed to use
deadly force I just saw a video
literally ten minutes ago of another
dashcam video of a guy gets popped for
DUI about to get cuffed he wrestles with
the cop steals the Taser shoots the cop
with a Taser while the cops all
flabbergast here each's into the car and
then pulls out a firearm shoots the cop
in the chest and drives off I mean I
understand why Brookes probably was
running because if he gets popped for
the DUI is going back on a probation
violation for the child abuse that he
was convicted of so desperate men do
desperate things that I understand but
this did not need to happen feel
terrible for his family feel terrible
for everyone involved but if you say you
can just blow over the limit and the
cops can just let you walk I mean I you
know how much I watch live PD and cops
I've never seen that happen this country
takes duis extremely seriously one
person per hour in America dies as a
result of a DUI and I'm not going to
drag other people's names into this but
we know how many famous politicians
athletes and celebrities have been
involved with fatal duis so sadly if
they change the racial dynamic of this
case I'm not even sure charges are
brought on the officer and the fact that
you have a doubt about that shows you
how messed up this system of justice has
become in this country greg gutfeld
let's get some final thoughts from you
well what's what's interesting to me and
I'll is how many this isn't like the
Floyd case there are really stark
differences of opinion about this video
I don't know if you've seen the ongoing
debate between Dan bond Gino and Geraldo
they both saw the video and they
disagree completely on it and they're
both very smart people they're both
friends this is a microcosm of a nation
that is arguing back and forth over a
specific video a video with incomplete
information
you know Jesse's right jesse is adding
information Juan adds information that
somebody else takes information away
it's not like you're talking about the
wardrobe malfunction at a Super Bowl
where we can all chat about it this
video with incomplete information which
is which which incorporates malfeasance
incorporates intoxication and then you
add this element of race this is not
like a fun harmless discussion this has
this video the one that the media just
pumps out and floods the airwaves with
so that we keep talking about it it
creates strife it creates conflict
that's why I say fawn Gina and Geraldo
are actually a microcosm of what to come
because we keep pumping out a video that
is incomplete and information I've been
noticing these patterns that the media
does lately and it's driving me crazy
so they pick up on this pattern which is
you know the police interactions that
end tragically okay but there are other
patterns that they are overlooking I
just noticed that almost every suspect
that has been arrested for arson in
these protests are white leftist women
what about that so should we start doing
large pieces about that trend or how
about the last three examples that we've
talked about of elder abuse of in the
rest home when the young man beat that
old elder that elderly man or the two
elderly the couple that were murdered in
the cemetery or the 92 year old who was
punched in the face in Britain I believe
it was in the Bronx of Brooklyn that we
were gonna do that story and it got
bumped those are okay
three examples and we're all pattern
recognition machines right so you see
that and you go okay that's elder abuse
but we don't do that story
we have white left is setting fire to
things arsonists but we don't do that
story we only do what the media programs
us to do and now that you see that you
cannot unsee that you look at the
statistics and you realize that we're
being fed lies all right
good discussion everybody I'm gonna look
up that Geraldo Bunji no discussion I
haven't seen that